in the lobby of Ramsey solutions they're
here Jared and Stephanie hey guys how
are you how are you welcome welcome
where do you guys live we live in
Murfreesboro Tennessee just around the
corner very cool so we're sort of
neighbors yeah excellent and you're here
to do your debt-free scream yes how much
have you paid off we paid off a hundred
and twenty two thousand dollars in
thirty six months wait that also
includes well in addition to that it's
about $30,000 in debt avoidance yeah you
mean you bought something or you paid
for something right we had some IVF
fertility treatments that were included
in that as well so really we're probably
around $150,000 range Wow and what was
your income through this time initially
we started I started just out of college
before Stephanie graduated and I was in
the mid-40s once we once she graduated
we really really kicked it up when we
were about 120 and then once we finished
we're in the 150 160 range great what do
you guys do for a living I'm an
occupational therapist and I'm an
engineering field for a commercial
mechanical contractor great very cool so
$150,000 household income these days
paid off a hundred and twenty-two and
avoided 30 so about $150,000 shift over
the last thirty six months
so what happened thirty six months ago
well a buddy of mine
Adam van Hooser I worked with a man
doing it for a really long time we were
sitting at work one day and he said hey
you got to listen to this guy
my family's followed his practices for a
long time and it's just it's really it's
really interesting he's really helping
people and I just kind of started
casually listening and I realized that I
needed help as well I didn't even
realize it so I kind of start working on
things myself before we got married have
you been married we've been together 10
years and married for this year okay
very cool all right so then you got
married in a year later what happened
that woke you guys up really made you go
after it graduate school loans we
started to see the loans adding up and
we realized we did not want to be
underneath all that so a lot of this was
student loan debt yes one hundred and
one thousand out of the 120 - what was
the rest of it was car loan and a credit
card
so you guys have lived on nothing we
have for a really long time it almost
just became second nature like three
years of your four-year marriage you've
lived on we have and it we did things a
little differently when she graduated we
we opened up a separate cycle checking
account it took her entire paycheck from
day one and just deposited directly into
separate taken account so that we
wouldn't even know it was there and then
each month we direct deposit or direct
withdrew money from that account
directly into her student loan pay off
just a little bit well and we actually
had to call Sallie Mae to to set up a
direct withdrawal that was way over
their limit they wouldn't do it online
we literally had to call them and tell
them how much we wanted to pay each
month they couldn't believe it yes which
in turn was the hardest part of this
whole process for me because once I was
in school for seven years and I finally
got my first big job and got my first
paycheck and yeah yeah I never really
saw it or got to do anything with it so
it's once we got the debt gone it's nice
to be able to actually live off both of
our incomes yeah I actually enjoy yeah
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else yes good
job you guys so when people hear you've
paid off a hundred and twenty two
thousand dollars worth of debt in thirty
six months and they say how did you do
that what do you tell them the keys are
for me the key is just its communication
I mean you have to have a partner that's
that's on the same plan a lot of people
say budget the budgets the key but to me
a budgets just it's just numbers on a
piece of paper if you don't have a
partner that's your accountability
partner that's there with you every day
that that was the biggest part of me I
have someone that's on board that really
encourages you and says look we can do
this I promise it there's lighted in
this tunnel when we're done with this it
will be so much better just stay with me
and that's that's what really kept us
going this entire time and he did he
told me you know I know this is gonna be
tough but if you stick with me we follow
the budget we stay with this plan you
know we will have the family we want
we'll have the house we want and he was
right we've got a great little
one-year-old and you missed that part of
the story yes we also we also sold the
dream car to help fund that little
one-year-old boys
which dream car was found s2000 Oh we
wouldn't get the car back though for the
baby no we're not gonna trade that
that's a good trade ever it's a good
trade but it's still a nice car yeah
awesome well congratulations you guys so
what was the the hardest thing so on
that car that was pretty difficult I'm
not gonna lie but I think what was a
little harder was the ham sandwich every
day just day in and day out for lunch
I never again what I'm saying I was so
cheap I didn't buy cheese it was just
ham and bread and that was hard for me
because every week I wanted to spend
more on the budget for the grocery bill
so that was probably our not that we had
a fight ever but our biggest
disagreement on the budget was how much
we were spending on food which we were
eating but Jarrod just wanted to eat
beans and I wanted beans and rice a
little more leniency of course with our
budget which I like oh well done and now
you can go out to eat yes that's fine
that's very cool yeah yeah whatever
you're broke people food was you're over
it when you're over it I don't yeah
mine's tuna fish man I had tuna fish
when we were broke everyday I hate tuna
fish my net worth goes down when I smell
too now you guys are incredible
congratulations what a sharp young
couple your future is so bright it's
unbelievable this kind of income you
know how to make money behave you know
how to work together there's so much out
there that you'll be able to do for
others and for yourself and for your
family tree and you are set yes now we
want to focus on setting up an account
for Easton for school and our
retirements and getting the house paid
off so we can just live life to the
fullest there you go you are on track I
love it truck and right through the baby
steps yeah all right Jared and Stephanie
from Murfreesboro Tennessee one hundred
and twenty two thousand dollars paid off
in 36 months making 40 when they started
all the way up to 150 now count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3
good job you two well done well done
well done
love it that is fabulous
you